Adam Schiff finally gets his moment in
the Sun Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
savage each other and world celebrities
flown over Granath on vergon Davos I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the venture Pierrot show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected and expressive VPN comm slash
been all his life Adam Schiff has just
wanted to be the center of attention the
talkies wanted and he was always the
geeky guy in school I mean I know I feel
it and he always wanted to be the guy in
the spotlight he would sit there at the
talent shows and think to himself but
I'm so much smarter than those dolts up
there playing guitar and now finally
Adam Schiff has got his moment to shine
and that's really what a lot of this is
about isn't it Adam Schiff who never
could stay away from a television camera
not for three years when he was claiming
he had secret information that President
Trump was in cahoots with the Russians
well now Adam Schiff is the house
impeachment manager after shepherding
through an impeachment process based on
insufficient evidence evidence so
insufficient that now the Democrats are
forced to try and pressure Republicans
in the Senate to subpoena new documents
and called me witnesses well now Adam
Schiff is out there and for hours on end
he is talking hours and hours and hours
now unsurprisingly unsurprisingly the
ratings suck from the ratings for this
impeachment they're not good you can
tell the American public are extremely
bored with it because the ratings are
not very good day one over the course of
the entire day apparently there were 11
million viewers over the course of an
entire day for an actual live
impeachment they just put that by way of
contrast like one at nightly primetime
show on the network's will get like 10
million 11 million viewers because I'm
in an unbelievable rate it's a fairly
good rating for one primetime show in
like half an hour okay to say that over
the course of the entire day in terms of
impeachment got like 11 million viewers
means that not very many people are
watching and as Joe contra from the hill
is reporting the primetime numbers from
the night one impeachment coverage are
really not very good total average
viewers from eight to eleven total
average viewers Fox News 3.5 million
MSNBC 2.5 million CNN 1.5 million in
other words basically everybody who is
already watching continue to watch and
nobody else showed up because guess what
those are very similar to the numbers
that you get I'm kind of a normal night
from these various networks
up a significant percentage because the
American people just don't care very
much and I don't blame them because
nothing new is happening this is all old
news and the other part of it is that
the Democrats obviously do not have the
goods if they did have the goods then
they wouldn't have to be pounding the
table the way that they are senator Ted
Cruz really sums it up yesterday he said
listen they don't have the facts they
don't have the law and so they're just
gonna pound that table there's an old
saying that if you have the facts you
bang the facts if you have the law you
bang the law if you don't have either
you bang the table well this afternoon
we've seen a whole lot of table banging
and at the end of the day we're in the
same spot we were in when we began the
day which is the House articles of
impeachment that were passed on a
partisan basis they don't meet the
constitutional standard of course
senator Cruz is right although I do
think that he should not say the phrase
table banging in conjunction with United
States senators because you just never
know what he's tuck we've seen too much
me too in the Senate to use that sort of
phrase in any case the house Democratic
impeachment managers according to the
New York Times began formal arguments in
the Senate on Wednesday presenting
meticulous and scathing case for
convicting president Trump don't you
love that sort of honest objective
journalism from the New York Times
meticulous and scathing not insufficient
not fact driven right meticulous and
scathing both at the same time oh my
gosh this must be the greatest legal
presentation since we saw the Scopes
trial I mean that really must be
unbelievable they made a meticulous and
scathing case for convicting president
Trump and removing him from office on
charges of abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress representative
Adam Schiff of California the lead House
prosecutor took the lectern in the
chamber as senators sat silently
preparing to weigh mr. Trump's fate
speaking in an even measured manner my
goodness this New York Times coverage
they may as well just get out the
massage oils and and just go to town he
accused the president of a corrupt
scheme to pressure Ukraine to help to
cheat in the 2020 presidential election
invoking the nation's founders and the
fears that a self-interested leader
might subvert democracy for his own
personal gain wait are you saying that a
self-interested leader like Adam Schiff
might subvert democracy for his own
political game mr. Schiff argued that
the president's conduct was precisely
what the framers of the Constitution had
in mind when they devised the remedy
impeachment one he said was quote as
powerful as the evil it was meant to
combat we're gonna get to what exactly
Adam Schiff had to say because Adam
Schiff accidentally to let the cat out
of the bag last night
he basically said we're not gonna allow
democracy to weigh in on this because we
cannot allow democracy dawei Anonymous
which is just spectacular all so he
suddenly broadened out the case for
impeachment to include things that are
blatantly unimpeachable he actually
suggested for example that it is an
impeachable offense for the president to
take any action that might benefit him
in an upcoming election
that's called everything a president
does the question is whether it is
illegitimate not whether it benefits him
in the upcoming election when the
president passes a tax cut that is
likely to benefit him in the upcoming
election when President Barack Obama
says to the Russians that he can provide
them flexibility after the election that
is likely to benefit him during the
election presidents spend their entire
ten years doing things that benefit them
for their reelection processes but the
the notion that that is in and of itself
impeachable is of course far too broad
instead you have to actually charge
something illegitimate like say bribery
which they didn't well get to more of
this in just one second you'll see how
insufficient shifts case is the media
still playing it up to the hill because
Adam Schiff had his moment in the Sun
and it was just like oh like a butterfly
just spreading its wings glorious and
colorful we'll get to all of that in
just one second first let us talk about
the reality as the year progresses
you're tired of schlepping boxes to the
post office I know you are I know that
you don't want to take all that stuff
and toss it in your car and then schlep
it over to the post office and then wait
in line at the post office post office
is great but you really want to spend
all that time and effort doing all of
that wouldn't be nice if you just take
those boxes like out to your mailbox
with all of the proper postage and then
we just get picked up from there good
news for you you can do this in it's
cheaper than going to the post office
when you use stamps calm stamps calm
brings all the services of the US Postal
Service directly to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices or an online seller shipping
out products even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps calm
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it once your mail is ready you just
hand it to your mail carrier or you drop
it in a mailbox it is indeed that simple
with stamps calm you get five cents off
every first class stamp up to four
percent off Priority Mail so you're
saving money and you're saving time
doesn't get better than that there's no
reason other than this why seven hundred
thousand small businesses already used
stamps calm why are you wasting your
time and wasting your money instead head
on over to stamps calm right now with my
promo code Shapiro you get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage ends digital scale
which is a great deal no long term
commitments no contracts just go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that is stamps calm promo code Shapiro
stamps calm never go to the post office
again
so the notion that Adam Schiff is
pushing forward which is that if you do
something that benefits you politically
that that is in and of itself
impeachable is of course far too broad
Josh Blackman is a constitutional law
professor at South Texas College of Law
in Houston he has a piece in The New
York Times I'm shocked they printed it
it's actually quite good today it's
called Trump acts like a politician
that's not an impeachable offense he
says the way things look President Trump
will most certainly not be removed from
office the precedent set by the articles
of impeachment however will endure far
longer and regrettably the House of
Representatives has transformed
presidential impeachment from a
constitutional parachute an emergency
measure to save the Republican freefall
into a parliamentary vote of
no-confidence if the house the house
seeks to expel mr. Trump because he
acted for his personal political benefit
rather than a legitimate policy purpose
mr. Trump's lawyers responded elected
officials almost always consider the
effect that their conduct might have on
the next election the president's
lawyers are right that behavior does not
amount to an abuse of power
politicians pursue public policy as they
see it coupled with a concern about
their own political future otherwise
legal conduct even when plainly
politically motivated but without moving
beyond a threshold of personal political
gain does not amount to an impeachable
abuse of power the house is
short-sighted standard will fail to
knock out Trump but if taken seriously
threatens to put virtually every other
elected official in peril the voters in
now Congress should decide whether to
reward or punish this self-serving
feature of our political order Josh
Blackman writes the first article of
impeachment turns on president Trump's
request that President Vladamir zalenski
of Ukraine announce an investigation of
hunter Biden's role with the energy
company buries m'x
mr. Trump wanted to learn about
potential financial corruption
concerning hunter realizing that such an
investigation would perhaps yield
greater scrutiny of Joe Biden the house
argues this request should potentially
harm from political rival was a quote
unquote abuse of power mr. Trump's
lawyers
on that the call was perfectly normal
yes that phrase actually appears in the
brief
regrettably parts of the brief are
written in a far too political tone but
the president's lawyers have raised an
important threshold issue in a
representative democracy they're right
elected officials almost always consider
the affect their conduct might have on
the next election Trump did not stand to
receive any money or property from the
Ukrainian president the house didn't
even bother to charge bribery as a
policy matter I disagree with Trump's
decision to ask for an investigation of
the Biden's even if warranted it should
have been avoided at all reasonable cost
the Republic would have been fine if we
never learn more about Purisima but
receiving a personal political benefit
does not transform and otherwise a legal
action into an impeachable conduct and
this of course is exactly right this is
why I've said all along if this was all
about 2020 then that's impeachable if
this was about 2016
that is not impeachable because the fact
is that the the 2016 interest is just
the mirror of the Democrats 2016
interest in Russia now Trump's interest
may be poorly based I think that parts
it is right all of his CrowdStrike
nonsense is a good example of the
president believe in conspiracy theories
that back his pre-existing point of view
and the president is particularly likely
to call it to fall into confirmation
bias but that does not make it impeach
able if he and his own mind was like
well we need to find out what happened
in 2016 because the American public has
an interest in finding out what happened
in 2016 and that involves looking into
Ukrainian corruption and biased toward
the Obama administration and precedent
of the Obama administration using
leverage against the Ukrainians well
then why wouldn't Purisima be relevant
in that context okay so with that as
back drop what gets to the arguments by
Adam Schiff who again he was it was just
amazing it was like Taylor Swift
suddenly realizing his political Adam
Schiff having his moment on the floor of
the Senate
those judge do my eyes popping out of
the head here's Adam Schiff explaining
we can this is where he lets the cat out
of the bag we literally he literally
says we cannot let Trump sit for an
election or he's going to steal it which
Democrats been saying all along but
which is extremely dangerous if you
suggest that the failure of impeachment
means that the next election is
illegitimate no matter what else happens
you have now raised the prospect of
actual political violence I mean we
heard this in 2016 from Democrats we
kept hearing that Donald Trump would not
accept the results of the election and
that because he would not accept the
results of the election that would lead
political chaos the Democrats are
telegraphing a year in advance that if
Donald Trump is not impeach they are not
going to accept the results of the
election under any circumstances
Schiff says we can't let the people vote
on this thing we cannot let the people
vote on this thing here's Adam Schiff
explaining why democracy is bad
the president's misconduct cannot be
decided at the ballot box for we cannot
be assured that the vote will be fairly
won okay so let's be real about this
what he is saying right now is that the
people of the United States should not
be able to vote on whether the president
is too corrupt to remain in office
instead if the election goes forward
Trump will cheat and the cheating will
mean that no matter what happens the
election is illegitimate but not only
should the American people not sound off
also Adam sure says this matter cannot
be decided in courts
so we also can't have courts
adjudicating subpoenas we can't have
courts adjudicating executive privilege
instead we just have to rush forward
with this thing given the seriousness of
the conduct at issue and its persistence
this matter cannot and must not be
decided by the courts which apart from
the presence of the Chief Justice here
today are given no role in impeachments
in either the house or the Senate being
drawn into litigation taking many months
or years to complete would provide the
president with an opportunity to
continue as misconduct he would remain
secure in the knowledge that he may tie
up the Congress in the courts
indefinitely okay so he says we can't
even wait for the courts so just to get
this straight Adam Schiff is now saying
we can't wait for the people to weigh in
because it's trumple cheap and we cannot
wait for the courts to sound off because
then Trump will cheat so this means that
there is only one branch of government
left right the executive can't sound off
on itself so that means there's only one
branch of government and that branch of
government is the legislature and that
legislature cannot be ruled by the
people who elected the legislature
instead it has to be Adam Schiff and his
cronies deciding who gets to sit and who
gets to go based on this premonition
that Trump is going to cheat in the next
election I mean it's hard to think of a
greater example of we need to burn the
village in order to save it so in order
to save democracy we have to say the
democracy literally will not be able to
function if Donald Trump remains as
president of the United States up to the
election which is a hell of a way to
talk about the most durable democ
see in the history of mankind I mean
that's oh that really is a hell of a way
to talk about it it's pretty astonishing
but of course the entire political
agenda here is to suggest that it's the
United States Senate that is abdicating
its duty if they do not impeach
President Trump now Adam Schiff was not
above mischaracterizing things it was
amazing to watch the media yesterday
fact-checking everything that the Trump
lawyers said which is fine in fact
checking nothing that Adam Schiff said
so Adam Schiff was saying things that
were blatantly untrue to take an example
Adam Schiff in the middle of this of
this impeachment hearing Adam Schiff
gets up and he just mischaracterizes the
Macmillan press conference so Mick
Mulvaney is the head of the Office of
Management and Budget he's also the
president's chief of staff and you
remember that he did this press
conference at which he said that quid
pro quos happen all the time
that Americans are constantly attempting
to pressure other countries to do things
and that's perfectly fine that's nothing
we should worry about okay what he did
not say is that it would be perfectly
fine for the United States to attempt
bribery on behalf of the President of
the United States right he never said
that but Adam Schiff who cannot help but
embellish because here's the thing he
has to embellish beyond the evidence
because the evidence is not sufficient
to sustain a conviction in the Senate so
he simply has to embellish beyond what
exactly people are saying so here he is
completely mischaracterizing the Mick
Mulvaney presser Mulaney didn't just
admit that the president withheld the
crucial aid appropriated by Congress to
apply pressure on Ukraine to do the
president's political dirty work he also
said that we should just get over it
should the Congress just get over it
should the American people just come to
expect that our presidents will
corruptly abuse their office to seek the
help of a foreign power to cheat in our
elections should we just get over it is
that what we've come to I hope and pray
that the answer is no okay so that is
not what mohini said I mean while veiny
did not say the president did a corrupt
thing get over Mick Mulvaney said Adam
Schiff just gets up there and he makes
up conversations in his own head
conversations that sustain his picture
of what exactly went on this is by the
way what was going on
when he gave that sort of fake
transcript of the Solinsky phone call
and it was not that he was getting up
there and he was doing a parodic reading
of the phone call he was just filling in
the gaps in the phone call with what he
hopes Trump was actually doing he has
this picture
he's gonna mischaracterize the picture
and he mischaracterizes all the time
we had that story from Politico within
the last 48 hours that he was completely
mischaracterizing in official
documentation Zinn letters to other
members of the House to Jerry Nadler
over at the House Judiciary Committee
he's blatantly mischaracterizing
correspondence including love partisan
rudy guiliani to suggest that paris was
setting up a meeting with zalenski the
president of ukraine and that was not
what the documents actually said so
editorship is a dishonest human being
his vier these deeply dishonest
will see the extent of that dishonesty
from the democrats as we continue in
just a moment first let's talk about
let's talk about getting the best
employees so let's say that you have
this fantastic producer he's great with
audio I mean really just a professional
let's call him Mike for example and
let's say that Mike whenever we do his
hip recruit is the first guy in the
rooms recommend that somebody else be
mentioned in this hip recruiter Adam
let's say that this guy has a list in
arm long just of people that he's
looking to clock in the zipper queer ad
and then let's say that Mike being the
perfect employee let's say that one day
he just comes in waltzes on in and says
you know you should talk about on the
show is you should talk about this topic
and I say to Mike well you know Mike I
literally talked about that 10 minutes
ago were you asleep in the control room
like what was happening he said no I'm
just focusing on audio but he was
actually asleep and we all know that he
was actually asleep or playing Dungeons
& Dragons or looking up the bass line on
the latest Metallica album right what we
don't know let's just say that that's
producer and finally you say you know
what we need somebody who's not
producing Mike then you would look to
zip recruiter cons if recruiter sends
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technologies zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job zip recruiter is
incredibly effective there's a reason
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter kind of quality
candidate through the site within the
very first date is important to get
hiring right so that you don't have
sound producers who spend most of their
days just compiling enemies list like
Stalin right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that is zip recruit comm
slash at Dai ly Wira zip recruiter comm
slash daily white zipper core is indeed
the smartest way to hire and they also
give me leverage of my own employees
which is pretty fantastic zip recruiters
comm slash daily wire ok back to back to
Schumer
back to Adam chef so chef gives it this
long meandering explanation of
everything that trumped any fills in all
the gaps with everything that he wishes
that he could prove that Trump did
without actually proving that from did
any of those things and then Chuck
Schumer emerges to sum up the testimony
and he says how could anyone listen to
Adam Schiff and not demand more
witnesses and documents and it's like
well up a second dude you really really
need to explain why it is that if you
thought this was so sufficient in the
house you are now calling for more
witnesses and documents in the Senate
this is the big question that the
Democrats will never answer they will
not answer it because the fact is they
could have done a complete investigation
and their answer is in the end they
don't want Trump to stand for election
because they believe that Trump was
legitimately elected in 2016 and that if
he wins in 2020 it will also be
illegitimate that's a lot more dangerous
to democracy than anything Trump did on
that phone call with Vladimir szalinski
having one party say and they do this
over and over it's not just with Trump
right this is Stacey Abrams who's
supposedly the legitimate governor of
Georgia you got Hillary Clinton
wandering around the woods of Chappaqua
explaining she's the actual President of
the United States when one party refuses
to accept the results of elections like
I really do not remember Republicans in
widespread fashion refusing to accept
the results of 2008 or 2012 with Barack
Obama we didn't like the results we
thought the results sucked we wish the
American people had bought it through a
little better a lot better but there are
very few Americans who were like you
know what that election was illegitimate
it was corrupt they stole the election
but Democrats are doing this with nearly
every election at this point here is
Chuck Schumer though saying we need more
witnesses we need more documents but
also this impeachment is on solid
footing I don't see how any senator
democrat or republican could sit on the
floor and hear Adam Schiff and not
demand witnesses and documents there
were so many powerful parts of his
speech that demanded witnesses and
documents so many things
what did mauvais me say before and after
his speech what well made him rejected
what did Bolton really think the the
documents right before the days of the
24th 25th and 26 which we've requested
July
very very important okay they're so
important than why didn't your buddies
in the house just wait for it and I am
amused by the Democrats claiming that we
need all these documents but no under no
circumstances should we hear from Hunter
Biden whose contact was at the center of
this entire debacle here's the atom chef
well maintaining the Republicans should
be open to all witnesses and all
documents here's Adam sure saying no why
would we call hunter Biden who's at the
center of this whole thing this isn't
like some fantasy football trade as I
said yesterday this isn't we'll offer
you this if you give us that will offer
you a witness that is irrelevant and
immaterial who has no relevant testimony
but a witness that will allow us to
smear a presidential candidate if you
want to get a legitimate witness that's
not a trade trials aren't trades for
witnesses um well why is it that you get
to pick the witnesses you got to do that
in the house and then you didn't call
the ones you want it so now you don't
get to determine who the witnesses are
who are called is pretty amazing
the Democrats are so out to protect
hunter Biden and Joe Biden that they're
basically willing to watch this
impeachment go down in flames simply
because they're not willing to do a
witness trade now my feeling is call
whatever you want I really don't care
like really I think the American people
generally have a right to know I don't
care if Bolton gets called I don't care
if Hunter Biden gets called I'm for all
of it coming out because I'm always in
favor of all of it coming out and I
don't have a lot of concerns at this
point that John Bolton is in even if I
did I wouldn't care that John Bolton's
gonna get up there and say Trump did X Y
or Z I think John Bolton is gonna say
exactly what his aide Fiona Hill said
but bottom line is that the Democrats
want to protect their witnesses and yet
they're out there saying that it is
utterly corrupt for Republicans not to
call the witnesses that Democrats want
it's pretty astonishing meanwhile the
Republicans are like okay this is just
this is ridiculous mark Meadows from
South Carolina he comes out and he was
like guys it's so ridiculous he was on
with sean hannity said we're giving out
aspirin
i mean like we're all falling asleep out
here listen we were giving out aspirin
in giant bottles today because you know
he just kept going on and on and get on
it and it jim jordan said it was about
lie after lie listen we quit counting
after we had twelve different false
statements made by Adam Schiff and the
fact is he knows better and he continues
to
tried to sell this to the American
people I I can tell you they're not
buying it we're not buying it but more
importantly the Senators are not buying
it I mean Martin meadows from North
Carolina not South Carolina by the way
and he is correct about this again the
American people have already decided on
this and most of all they've decided
that all this is boring meanwhile
President Trump always has on his own
worst enemy on this sort of stuff so
Trump is speaking in Davos and Trump
suggests that the Democrats they don't
have the material that they need which
of course suggests that maybe they
should have the material and that he
should turn the material over what he
actually means that we have the material
the Democrats don't have the material
and so they are speculating about what
is in material they don't have but this
comes off like Trump is trying to hide
material obviously we're doing very well
I got to watch enough I thought our team
did a very good job but honestly we have
all the material they don't have the
material so that came off like he's
trying to hide the material in reality
he's just saying we have all the
material we know what's in the material
they don't they're speculating but you
could certainly read it the way the
Democrats are trying to read that Val
Demmings the house impeachment manager
one of the house impeachment managers
for the Democrats said that's that's
real time obstruction oh no again you
could take him to court I'm waiting for
it but apparently you can't go to the
courts and you can't go to the American
people only Adam Schiff can save us
we're gonna get to the media just
flaunting orgasming over Adam shifts
performance yesterday I mean it truly is
amazing there they are now meg Ryan and
when Harry Met Sally there at the
restaurant and they've ordered the eggs
and they are just going to town we'll
get to that in just one second first let
us talk about the inevitability of death
Oh
pretty dark right the fact is that we
will all have to pay taxes unfortunately
and we will all have to die and that you
may be related but the reality is that
as you approach your death every minute
of every day you might be thinking how
can I ensure against this on behalf of
my family maybe you're not that dark
maybe you're just like you know what I
need insurance well the place to go
would be policy genius calm policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home in auto insurance disability
insurance life insurance is a moral
obligation it is it is something that
you need to do if you are a responsible
adult if you have a wife
have kids if you have family you don't
want to deprive them of your income
stream if god forbid something should
happen to you it's gonna be bad enough
if you plotz leaving them without any
money to deal with it's gonna be really
rough instead go to policy genius and
get the life insurance you need policy
genius will always get the future wrong
you may not know when you're going to
plotz but you can insure against it
better get life insurance right policy
genius calm go check them out right now
at policy genius calm okay so the media
for their part are over the moon about
Adam chef this is Adam shifts moment
guides it's his moment there is a slight
montage of the media just going hog wild
hog wild over Adam chef like a teenage
boy his first copy of hustler here we go
the media just enjoying the spectacle of
manly man Adam Schiff this this is
really I am Spartacus moment where you
know people really need to stand up and
I do think I wrote the same thing which
was that this visit speech really aimed
at the better angels and I think gotten
ship did a really great job but I really
thought was just amazing about ships
presentation is he was speaking not just
to the 100 people in the room he was
speaking to 100 years in the future this
is a speech that kids are gonna be given
in 2060 it you know at University
projects there are people in the Senate
that call themselves lawyers they are
admiring him even if they will never
admit it publicly a very very powerful
and forceful speech to an almost two and
a half hours if he was listening he
heard a very very strong case from Adam
Schiff why he the President of the
United States should be convicted and
removed from office well I mean I
haven't seen the media this says in
Chris Matt he's got a tingle up his leg
about the rock Obama I haven't seen him
this excited my goodness
I mean take a cold shower guys CNN's
Jeffrey Toobin was dazzled dazzled
he said that Adam shifts argument was
literally the second-best courtroom
address he had ever heard in his entire
life in his entire life which like um no
here's Jeff
Jeffrey Toobin just over the moon about
all of this can't come himself now Jeff
you can come on guys let's go let's do
this thing go I thought it was dazzling
I thought the way he wove through
both the facts of the case and the
historical context was really remarkable
it was the second best courtroom address
since it's like a courtroom that I ever
heard the argument that the president
extorted or bribed or whatever criminal
term you want to use the president of
Ukraine to get his political dirt on on
John Joe Biden in return for our three
hundred ninety million dollars to
taxpayer money I mean it's there if you
want to see it and the question is if
you want to see it dazzling dazzling I
haven't been this excited since I saw
Katz for the third time that day says
Jeffrey Toobin I haven't been this
excited since Dame Judi Dench put on fur
and walked around with James Corden okay
so just a couple of things about that so
Jeffrey Toobin you hear right there he
says he made an absolutely brilliant
case that there was extortion and
bribery going on well here's the thing
extortion and bribery is Jeffrey Toobin
one those are statutory crimes you know
what's not in any of the impeachment
charges extortion or bribery weird weird
if you can make that strong a case the
most brilliant legal case he's ever
heard as you heard Jeffrey Toobin say
the second most ever ever the first most
was the time that Jeffrey Toobin was in
third grade and he argued in mock trial
that time was the best but the second
best was Adam Schiff well if you really
made that dazzling in cases so dazzling
jazz scheduling if he was so dazzling
then why didn't the Democrats include
the charges that he talked about okay
meanwhile the other members of the media
also going crazy over this and I mean
literally crazy Joe Lockhart who is he
was an analyst for CNN tweeted this out
overheard convo between two Republican
senators who only watch Fox News is this
stuff real I haven't heard about any of
this before I thought it was all about a
server if half the stuff shift is saying
is true we're up bleeps Creek hope the
White House has exculpatory evidence
right so that was at 11:13 a.m.
yesterday and he's wheats that out and
then about ten minutes later he tweets
out okay maybe I made up the
conversation but you know that's exactly
what they're thinking really so you're
just making up conversations now in your
own mind about what Republicans are
thinking watching this thing truly
really Salas and meanwhile over at MSNBC
they were in
that people are not paying closer
attention to the impeachment why is it
people watching why rachel maddow
getting very angry Chris Hayes wearing
Rachel Maddow's glasses so she can't
wear her glasses at the same time
there's only one pair of glasses over at
MSNBC and if Rachel Maddow is wearing
them and Chris Hayes cannot be they're
both on screen at the same time and thus
only he can wear glasses everyone very
very upset because senators were leaving
Senator Dianne Feinstein was like this
is boring I'm out I have to say old
Diane Feinstein is one of my favorite
Democrats hey I'm Dianne Feinstein's a
terrible senator she's been a senator
nearly as long as I have been alive on
this earth in the state of California
and Dianne Feinstein's been an awful
senator forever she of the lifeless eyes
dars eyes but yesterday dianne
feinstein's like this boring I'm out
she's like I'm old I'm done and she went
home took a couple of pills took a nap
and so people on MSNBC were super mad
like why can't you guys even stay of our
lifetime grace why can't I have my
glasses as Rachel Maddow there are some
sketch artists in the room who are
actually drawing some pictures of what
senators are doing including senators
who are sleeping but it is a little bit
weird that we all thought it was within
the rules but they had to be there these
people's jobs is to do this I mean this
is literally the job if you find it too
annoying or frustrating or uncomfortable
to sit for eight hours and listen you
can resign tomorrow and go get another
job oh well I mean you could get a job
on MSNBC like Claire McCaskill after you
lose your Senate seat you could do that
and sit right next to Chris Hayes he was
wearing the glasses of outrage she
wasn't wearing the glasses of outrage so
she was more slightly perturbed he was
wearing the glasses of MSNBC outraged he
was very perturbed yesterday okay note
to the media
no one cares I'm sorry to break it to
you people do not care seriously they
don't care they're tired of this they're
bored with it even if people want Trump
impeach they know this is going nowhere
and so this has become just a foregone
conclusion and you guys can can you guys
can just revel in your own in your own
fantasy world where all of this deeply
matters but the reality is that while
you are meeting about all of this while
you're just sitting there and you are
and you are obsessed with every little
detail
most Americans have jobs in lives and
most Americans are not all that
interested in any of this and that's bad
news for the Democrats because as we
move toward 2020 that means that the
focus is going to shift from this whole
impeachment silliness to the actual 2020
race and right now there is an open
battle breaking out between Bernie
Sanders and Joe Biden we're gonna get to
that in just one second first if you
know anything about me you most likely
heard me talk about my art and support
for the pro-life cause you may also
remember the last year i streamed my
podcast live from the March for Life in
DC gave a speech to the hundreds of
thousands of people marching for the
cause by the way President Trump will be
the first sitting president to speak in
the March for Life this year which is
just fantastic well what you may not be
aware of is how much grief this caused
the daily wire from our political
opponents adversaries leftist censors
our advertisers were targeted by
left-wing quote-unquote media watchdog
through the left-wing hacks we lost a
bunch of revenue for no reason because I
didn't say anything wrong and I would
say every single word that I said at
that march over again a thousand times
that was not the first time it nor will
it be the last time that we are attacked
in an attempt to shut down pro-life
voices that is why we are teaming up
with live action so live action is a
wonderful pro-life charity run by my
friend Lila Rose I give money personally
to live action they do incredible work
in the space from raising awareness and
education on the abortion issue to
undercover videos that expose Planned
Parenthood and other abortion clinics
and they have met with the left-wing
censorship the EC on social media they
were banned from advertising on Twitter
because they went after Planned
Parenthood they've been banned from
Pinterest altogether for quote unquote
spreading medical misinformation like
babies are babies and so we are going to
help them out and you should help out
the pro-life cause right now when you
become a daily wire.com member a portion
of your membership not only your your
whole membership helps keep us on the
air giving the pro-life message out
there but also from now until January
31st a portion of any daily wire.com
membership will be donated to live
action with promo code live action to
support awareness and education around
the world on this issue so join daily
we're calm make your pro-life voice
heard you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so as we draw nearer to the 2020
election it becomes obvious that this
whole impeachment thing is going
absolutely nowhere to the great
disappointment of many people both right
and left there's actually a group out
there today that have pushed out an ad
suggesting that president Pence is gonna
be a thing that Mike Pence is actually
going to be President of the United
States that of course is not true
President Trump will be in office when
the election takes place meanwhile I'm
amazed it is amazing that the the sort
of hypocrisy of the media when it comes
to who should testify and who should not
Joe Biden was asked yesterday whether he
would testify whether he would sit as a
witness if he was called before the
Senate and he has said before that he
will not which apparently according to
the according to the Democrats amounts
to obstruction of Congress right because
Donald Trump has said that he's
asserting executive privilege over
people and that they cannot testify and
then he was charged with the destruction
of Congress and impeached for it in the
house Joe Biden is openly saying he will
not cooperate if subpoenaed that's
pretty much the same thing here is Joe
Biden repeating that this is a
constitutional issue and we're not going
to turn it into a farce into some kind
of political theater they are trying to
turn in a political theater but I want
no part of being any part of that and I
have no problem as you'll find out the
rest of this campaign debating Trump
debating the Majority Leader debating
Lindsey grant debating any of these guys
I don't have any problem you look at my
career 36 years in the Senate they had
problems debating me well no they
actually did not have any problem
debating you which is why you've been a
failed presidential candidate 82 times
but Joe Biden saying that he will not
sit again it's not gonna look great for
him in 2020 when President Trump dumps
on the hunter Biden story right that
hunter Biden thing ain't going away it
isn't his son is an arrow do well a
drug-addled never do well apparently for
most of his adult life and the fact that
he was going around picking up bags of
cash for having the last name Biden it's
not gonna look good
for all Joe meanwhile Bernie Sanders has
open up the guns on Joe Biden because
he's got two weeks to win Iowa basically
if Biden wins Iowa the sucker is over
before it begins so that means that that
Bernie really does have to win Iowa his
people are now releasing ads targeting
Joe Biden for suggesting that he would
restructure Social Security one of the
things that his whole
Arius about the Democratic Party is that
their ads basically rip on people for
saying practical things the reality is
that Social Security is unsustainable it
is unsustainable it is a giant pyramid
scheme by which a bunch of young people
are paying into a fund they will never
see and yet everybody who is older in
the country is being told that we are
going to adjust the benefits that you
receive by cost of living so it's not
dependent on what you contributed it's a
defined benefits plan it is not a
defined contribution plan which means
that my grandmother paid in like fifty
bucks a month forty years ago and she's
receiving a couple thousand dollars a
month from Social Security good for her
the problem is that everybody else is
paying for it that's gonna have to be
restructure and everybody knows it's
gonna have to be restructured everybody
knows that we're gonna have to either
raise the retirement age or we're going
to have to lower the benefits that's not
for people who are current retirees
that's for future retirees everybody
knows that Joe Biden once said it and
now Bernie Sanders is going after him
because in Bernie Sanders world anytime
you say you're gonna lower benefits this
means that you are evil because money
grows on trees and Bernie Sanders can
simply pull it directly out of his
rather elderly posterior here is a
Bernie Sanders going after Joe Biden
when I argued that we should freeze
federal spending ice meant Social
Security as well I meant Medicare
Medicaid
I meant veterans but I meant every
single solitary thing in the government
and I not only tried it once I tried it
twice I tried it the third time and I
tried it a fourth time
well we've got some bad news for them we
are not going to cut Social Security
we're gonna expand and so that is that
is pretty brutal
now what biden is saying is he's saying
that particular quote is taken out of
context but the reality is that biden
has said in the past that he would be
interested in revising Social Security
because this is what any practical
politician in history has said okay that
is a reality now Joe Biden is firing
back and he is saying that Bernie
Sanders is basically a liar so this
thing is starting to get ugly here is it
Joe Biden going after Bernie they even
accused Joe Biden of supporting Paul
Ryan's cuts to Social Security Bernie's
campaign is not telling the truth Joe
Biden has repeatedly voted to save
Social Security he and President Obama
beat back Republican attempts to
privatize it and in 2012 Joe Biden even
said he didn't support those cuts to
Paul Ryan we will be no part of a
voucher program or the privatization of
Social Security
Biden's plan protects Social Security
and will increase benefits
Bernie's negative attacks won't change
the truth okay so the fact is that he is
correct that the that Bernie Sanders is
lying about his record but Bernie
Sanders is also corrected in the past
Joe Biden has made statements talking
about how we do need to restructure
Social Security because he is not a
completely insane human being Bernie
happens to be completely insane and so
he can just keep saying that we are
going to sign endless checks to people
without any source of funding for those
endless checks but all of this is
beginning to get too old Joe so old Joe
yesterday was on the campaign trail and
he was approached by a reporter not sure
from which outlet and this reporter
started asking about Joe Biden about
about Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden turns
around and basically goes nuts on the
reporter now if this had been Donald
Trump we've been look at his attack on
the press look at his attack on the
press but it's Joe Biden and so we just
say it's okay
was it his apology mr. vice president
it's okay he apologized for saying that
I was corrupt he didn't say anything
about whether or not I was telling the
truth less Social Security okay and then
he had pounds pumps the guy in the chest
and walks away Oh Joe I don't losing it
out there
old Joe can't lose another meanwhile Joe
Biden sir a half attacking Bernie Bernie
is sort of half attacking Biden but it's
obvious that they are not fond of one
another at this point Joe Biden was on
MSNBC's Morning Joe and he explained
that he will not call Bernie a liar over
the Social Security smear he said
sometimes the staff gets out of the
candidate trying to give Bernie a way
out Bernie's not taking that way out by
the way did Bernie Sanders lie about you
I don't know where the Bur look
sometimes campaign staff gets a little
ahead of the candidate you know it's the
same thing Bernie someone with staff
wrote and said Joe Biden is corrupt and
Bernie personally apologized me I accept
the apology but the facts are that I've
have a hundred percent rating from the
groups that rate Social Security those
who support Social Security I think at a
minimum was taken out of context what
they did and that of course is is his
way of attempting to lower the tension
because he feels like he's winning an
Iowa I mean while bernie is route is
ramping it up the new york times is
reporting that Sanders has opened up the
guns mr. Sanders newly combative posture
has been met with some relief inside his
campaign with the two men competing for
an overlapping slice of working-class
voters some top aides have been quietly
urging mr. Sanders to draw more explicit
contrast with the former vice president
not only was such an offensive help Mr
Sanders
whittle away at mr. Biden's support some
advisors believe it would also satisfy
supporters and donors to Mr Sanders who
crave a fight some also think he pulled
punches against Hillary Clinton in 2016
to his detriment since the fall they've
encouraged him to go after Biden
aggressively on the debate stage a
strategy Sanders followed tepidly during
the debate last week in Des Moines some
advisors had prodded Sanders to confront
Biden on Social Security and were
frustrated the topic did not come up
Sanders seemed to Telegraph his
willingness to engage in rougher
campaigning during a question-and-answer
session with reporters this month in
Iowa City said we will contrast records
nothing wrong with that that is what the
furious company is about and his aides
are saying that he's beginning to open
up
guns as I say right now the polling in
Iowa does have Joe Biden significantly
ahead there are two polls with Joe Biden
six points ahead the minute they show
Biden wins Iowa this thing is over for
Bernie Sanders and Bernie Sanders knows
it again his entire campaign is based on
pie-in-the-sky kind of nonsense so why
the hell would he not attack Joe Biden
over restructuring Social Security which
is the thing that everybody knows has to
get done at some point okay meanwhile
President Trump is over in Davos and he
is not the celebrated voiceover into
office the celebrated voiceover in Davos
his 17 year old grandson Berg I know
she's havin teen I didn't know she was
17 I mean the way the media portray her
it's like she's 14 but she's actually a
17 year old
that does not mean she's an adult out it
means she's a public figure and she is
due for any sort of criticism any other
public figure would receive I know I was
reading a syndicated column when I was
17 18 years old what a lot of dumb stuff
being 17 and 18 means that sometimes you
say dumb stuff so that's not on Greta
Sundberg it's on everybody who takes her
seriously and the fact that greta
thunderbird is propped up there as some
sort of great intellectual force is
truly astonishing because again her
entire spiel is I'm a child and I'm very
angry sir that turns higher thing she's
a child and she's angry and she says
this right she's not hiding the ball
she's a child who's angry and she goes
around yelling at adults and the adults
who wish to use that anger as a sort of
club with which to beat people who
disagree they say look at this child
look at this child this is an angry
child why don't you listen to this angry
child
my answer is I generally don't listen to
angry children I have two of them
there's no reason for me to listen to
angry children that I don't actually
love I like my own kids I don't know
grant Sundberg maybe she's wonderful no
clue but I'm not sure why listen to her
yell about global warming when she
proposes solutions that are patently
insane
and I say that advisedly her solutions
to global warming are patently insane
and yet they are propped up by everybody
in the media she's a great heroine we
put her on the cover of magazines
because she her entire agenda is to go
around and scream at adults about how
terrible the adults are because they're
not doing what she wants them to do so
what this sort of raises the question
what exactly does she want them to do
right because after all if she is
screaming at the adults aren't doing it
it would be good to know what exactly
she wants them to do so here's what
Greta Sundberg wants the adults to do
and this has been again the adult al
gore shows happens like I'm here the
earth has a fever and we're alone
it's the only thing that can cure this
fever the Al Gore fever so he was there
praising her she's so important it's
deeply important to Greta Thun birth 17
year old global warming wunderkind
apparently here was her solution her
solution to the problem of global
warming and it is crazy guys we don't
need a low-carbon economy
we don't need to lower emissions our
emissions have to stop if we are to have
a chance to stay below the 1.5 degree
target and until we have the
technologies that at scale can put our
emissions - - that we must forget about
Net Zero we need real zero not net zero
so net zero means that we sort of don't
produce any additional emissions beyond
the rates of which we are currently
producing real zero so real zero means
that you actually shut down the entire
economy of the world of the world and
lest you think that I am exaggerating
what exactly she is calling for here is
Greta Sundberg what she actually said at
Davos and she was praised by the media
for this the real reason she's getting
praised of course is cuz she yells at
the adults and what the left loves to do
is prop up children who yell adults and
that way if you attack what the children
are saying if you say listen seems like
a nice enough young woman like I'm not
arguing with her passion that's fine she
has an agenda that's fine - I'm arguing
with her agenda that way the let's can
say you're attacking a child don't you
see you're attacking they do the same
thing with regards you gun control
they love trotting out children so that
they can say you are attacking this poor
victimized child and it's like well no I
think that the arguments bad not taking
the kid but the reason that the left
props are up is that she says crazy
things but then she also says that she's
mad at the adults why won't you listen
to the children the children are the
wisest among us here's Greta thumb burn
ripping on the adults and this is what
of course has made her a media
phenomenon I've been warned that telling
people to panic about the climate crisis
is a very dangerous thing to do but
don't worry it's fine trust me I've done
this before and I can assure you it
doesn't lead to anything
and and for the record where were
children tell you to panic we're not
telling you to go on like before we're
not telling you to rely on technologies
that don't even exist today at scale and
that science says perhaps never will
we're telling you to panic we're telling
you to panic I'm telling you to panic I
said I wanted you to panic she said this
one year ago I came to Davos and told
you our house is on fire I said I wanted
you to panic now normally when anybody
tells you to panic that's a bad idea
when a child tells you to panic or like
know your child I'm not gonna panic over
the possible increase in global
temperature of at maximum four degrees
Celsius according to the IPCC over the
course of the next century in fact what
we should be attempting is mitigation
right we should be attempting is
adaptation this is not to say that we
can't take measures that would lower
carbon emissions in fact the United
States fracking for natural gas has
lower our carbon emissions dramatically
nuclear power lowers power lowers
emissions dramatically but her actual
proposal the one that's being praised
quote we demand at this year's World
Economic Forum participants from all
companies banks institutions and
governments immediately halt all
investments in fossil fuel exploration
and extraction immediately end all
fossil fuel subsidies and immediately
and completely divest from fossil fuels
every company is supposed to stop using
fossil fuels every government is
supposed to stop using fossil fuels
every institution is supposed to stop
using fossil fuels she says we don't
want these things done by 2050 2030 even
twenty twenty-one we want this done now
it may seem like we're asking for a lot
and you will of course say that we are
naive but this is just the very minimum
amounts of effort that is needed to
start the rapid sustainable transition
um well since you are talking about the
end of civilization as it currently
exists yeah that seems like a lot I'm
just gonna put it out there that that
seems like a lot and it does not seem
justified by the available evidence it
is always easier to get people to rally
around a problem than it is to get them
to rally around a solution when it comes
to big problems you should actually be
providing real solutions not nonsense
and then trotting out children to claim
that if you don't embrace solutions that
literally no one is willing to embrace
right Al Gore would not implement that
he would not if you were President of
the United States he would not the Paris
Accords were not this there's not
adult on the planet who sees this
proposal as anything other than patently
insane and yet they're all out there
like credit Sundberg hero of the
Republic it's so it's so irritating and
so silly
okay time for a quick thing that I like
and then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things that I like today so I
put this in things I hid originally but
it's actually a thing that I love so
Taylor Swift has a new Netflix
documentary and they released the
trailer for this thing and it is
spectacular it is spectacularly awful it
is wonderful in every way it's it's a
parody of itself sort of like the cat's
trailer like you're watching her like
this can't be real this can't be really
this isn't real right like she's making
fun of herself right no wrong it is
completely sincere it is completely and
utterly sincere now listen I'm no Taylor
Swift fan I used to have this argument
with my producers Tanja many a day we
would argue about the merits of Taylor
Swift and I would say she's over in and
say no she's the greatest songwriter
over the last 190 years well I think we
can both agree
Senya wherever you are today I think we
can both agree that this particular
documentary trailer is one of the
greatest things in history and also one
of the worst things in history so Taylor
Swift you have to recognize the Taylor
Swift's whole schpeel is that she was
the the young girl who wrote her own
songs and was charming and somewhat
innocent and then she had to feminist
hit up gang because she got pressure
from the media and the media said where
is Taylor Swift why won't Taylor Swift
sound off about same-sex marriage it's
Taylor Swift silence is deafening on
transgender bathrooms
why won't Taylor Swift comment on
whether Fallon Fox should be able to
fight women where is Taylor Swift when
you need her discussing climate change
and Taylor Swift after a few years of
this and saying nothing she decided you
know what they're right I got to get
woke or go broke baby so now they've cut
this this Netflix documentary trailer
and it is so good that I'm gonna play it
for you I'm going to stop and start it
because I must comment on it every
elements of this is glorious from the
background music to the cues to the
language that she uses it is also
manipulative it is also mechanistic you
can see all the years moving in
real-time she's trying to show that this
is the authentic Taylor Swift all it
shows that she was always a media
creation and it is wonderful and
every way there's a movie if you haven't
seen it and you don't mind like r-rated
human like a very r-rated humor there's
a movie called pop star never stop never
stopping and the basic plot of the movie
is that there is a a person who is a pop
star played by Andy Samberg and he cuts
into album becomes a big hit and then he
starts to lose popularity and he
realizes that he has to go political and
one of the songs that he cuts is a song
called equal rights I'm not gay
and the entire is about same-sex
marriage and how wonderful it is but he
keeps having to interject and explain
that he's not gay because he's
uncomfortable with the fact that anybody
might think he's gay so he keeps talking
about people should be able to marry
each other sports it's fantastic and the
entire movie is basically that okay this
trailer is the trailer for pop star
never stop never stopping to Taylor
Swift edition let's play this thing game
it's fantastic just gonna go have fun no
one out there that I know of in the
audience actively hates me not get dead
face ready throughout my whole career
label executives would just say a nice
girl doesn't force their opinions on
people
a nice girl smiles and waves and says
thank you I became the person everyone
wanted me the closet please it's
spectacular it's so spectacular the sad
background piano music oh my god it's so
sad
it was the label executives guys it
wasn't her it wasn't that she was
working in order to have a big career by
not offending people label executives
said crazy things like don't be mean to
people and say thank you and please and
eat with a fork and knife and keep your
elbows off the table and don't jump into
politics cuz you're just a musician but
they were holding me back you know they
were enshrouding me if you actually
could see this this is why I should
subscribe you can see this nonsense they
actually have in the footage her putting
on like a black cloak because it's just
showing how they were in shrouding her
enshrouding her in the cloak patriarchy
but don't worry guys the music will rise
and as the music rises you will see the
Taylor Swift is in fact a woke political
feminist let the music rise Taylor free
yourself Taylor go Taylor go I I think
that Taylor Swift
nobody physically saw me for a year and
that was what I thought they wanted I
had to deconstruct an entire belief
system toss it out and rejected American
follow me
it woke me up from constantly feeling
like I was fighting for people's respect
I thought school boy it was happiness
without anyone else's input
[Music]
I need to be on the music did you hear
my favorite part of is there's so many
good things about this trailer so many
good things stop it for a second please
so many great things about this trailer
so I love the part they're like I
disappeared for a year there's footage
of her no one saw her for a year except
the camera except the camera that was
following her for a year apparently and
then I it's like every elements of this
is so wonderful every element of it is
so glorious and then she she realized
that she was that she wasn't living for
herself guys the hundreds of millions of
dollars that she was worth and the
throngs of admiring young women it was
not for her she wasn't she wasn't living
for herself she was living for the label
executives guys and then she realized it
was time to use her voice in a new way
to say the most hackneyed trite
politically left this garbage you could
possibly think of to cut a song about
gay marriage 10 years after it was
legalized I mean that was what was
necessary and that is when the music
started to rise and she became a
feminist hero and oh my god and then the
little cutaway where she's to show that
she's authentic that these songs are not
produced by other people the little
cutaway of her with like her friend on
the couch
I mean me hee hee like oh my god guys we
just came up with it we just came up
with Sergeant Pepper guys it's
unbelievable this is ah the genius the
workings of the mother oh ok the rear
just we have to finish the trailer
because we have to because it is
obligated by law for us to finish this
trailer is if we do not then we will
have it miss served our own constituents
but play the end of this trailer it's so
good it's so good I feel really good
about not feeling muzzled anymore she's
not muzzled guys doing
it's beyond my scope I know in this
moment
what are you doing attorney Mumbai party
shoes for vocals good you've never
really gotten a good take without them
halfway Wow
she's it's beyond everything I thought I
knew well yes what's weird about that
it's what I thought I knew is that she
was a complete media creation and
creation by her managers and now what I
think I know is that she's a complete
media creation and a creation by her
managers except now they told her that
she better get woke and so she got woke
and now they produced an entire top
piece documentary about her to explain
that she was always woke is just she was
muscled because nothing says muzzled
quite like being a hundred million
dollar singer who can say anything she
wants at any time and say literally
anything that that's muzzling guys it
was just I mean it was like the Soviet
Union in her life and then she broke
free she broke free of the shackles and
she became a fierce independent fierce
fierce with an S at the end fierce
independent woman okay this is what this
is why Donald Trump is president I'm
sorry to tell you this this is why
Donald Trump is president because
everyone who watches the thing who has a
semi functional prefrontal cortex
understands how produced and stupid this
is and the fact that these are our
cultural betters lecturing us all and
that and that we're supposed to take
this seriously
and now when Taylor Swift says I think
Donald Trump is a sexist we're supposed
to be like oh my god you know what
choose muzzled before but now she speaks
only truth Taylor Swift she's because
only fruit she's a feminist hero I love
it so much I want to take that I want to
frame the entire trailer I want that
entire trailer on my wall so I can just
hit that button and revel in the
sophistry and the production value and
the over-the-top self-congratulation of
the celebrity class whereas Ricky
Gervais when you need a medic tacular
stuff and anybody who buys into the myth
of Taylor Swift at this point my
goodness guys that is one of the most
produced human beings on planet earth
and it just shows and the attempts at
authenticity are so rich and rewarding
and wonderful already I've run out of
time for things I hate because I just
loved that trailer too much I'm sorry I
loved it too much but I wish to remind
you their wish there's actually a pretty
cool thing out there that I should
recommend we sent our own Michael Mills
away from the office so that in and of
itself is excellent we sent him to DC
and he's doing a brand new podcast
co-hosted by Senator Ted Cruz titled
verdict it is actually like a review of
the
they're doing the impeachment trial
they're doing it like in real time as
the thing ends they're putting together
this podcast so you get like this
real-time update on what's going on from
senator Cruz who of course is watching
this thing first in and it's involved in
everything
Michael Knowles being useful for once go
check out verdict on Apple podcast
Spotify anywhere else you get your
podcast is pretty cool and it is worth
it is indeed worth the listen alrighty
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow for much
much more I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel lie down scoop
technical producer Austin Stephens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]
you